bonjour Luc Lemoine bonjour
des records bravo en tout cas et puis
sur Europe 1 aussi le matin l'après-midi
tout le temps en fait Jean-Luc Lemoine
vous pouvez pas venir faire une
chronique non pas non c'est prévu c'est
prévu il faut juste virer Maxime
une petite problématique une actualité
effectivement très très chargée en cette
on s'est rentré est-ce que ce que ces 8
vous montre pas trop
j'ai plein de bons souvenirs assez vite
donc oui ça manque maintenant je suis
bien occupé je suis très heureux à
France Télévisions
elle va peut-être voir une petite
séquence aussi samedi d'Henri on en a
aussi un extrait la bande-annonce de
votre émission qui cartonne
dans un nouveau décor une ambiance
joueuse on cherche un artiste des
sketchs
inoubliable
le tout dans deux émissions à la suite
et voilà le travail deux fois plus de
rire tous les samedis des 13h35 sur
France 3 et sur la plateforme france.tv
c'est votre cinquième saison succès
d'audience c'est ça plus de 1 million de
téléspectateurs 1,4 millions de
téléspectateurs un million 5 a quasiment
franchement quand vous avez commencé à
la faire cette émission vous pensez que
il y aura un tel succès honnêtement on
espérait sinon on y serait pas allé mais
on pensait pas que ça prendrait aussi
vite parce qu'on a commencé on était à
600000 téléspectateurs et très très vite
ça basculé on a dépassé le million et on
s'est installé avec un public super
fidèle nous envoie des messages d'amour
j'ai jamais autant de messages de
sympathie dans la rue et au marché aussi
notamment si vous faites le marché c'est
bien ça
c'est plus sécuritaire
qu'est-ce qu'on a vu la grande
distribution notamment certaines pas
toutes c'est important de de le
souligner c'est quoi le sel de cette
émission pourquoi ça prend
le succès de l'émission je crois que
c'est une émission feel good mais
aujourd'hui c'est presque
c'est presque pas good sur tous les
plateaux il y a des clashs et tout nous
on vient pour passer un bon moment on
prend les gens à la sortie du repas du
du samedi et puis on s'amuse et puis on
convoque aussi un petit peu de nostalgie
ça fait du bien à tout le monde je crois
vous avez des nouveautés cette année ou
on ne change pas une équipe qui gagne on
a des nouveaux chanteurs qu'on
connaissait pas Joe Dassin
si on a on a on se retrouve toujours au
niveau des des jeux et puis c'est
surtout un nouveau format la grande
nouveauté de cette année c'est que avant
on était sur 90 minutes maintenant il y
a deux émissions de 52 minutes qui se
suivent il y a juste une petite pub
entre les deux comme c'est un signe que
ça doit bien marcher et puis on repart
pour 52 minutes et vous les enregistrez
des émissions
vous les enregistrez plusieurs sur une
journée exactement ça c'est la réalité
de la télévision aujourd'hui mais
on enregistre ça par série ouais le défi
Jean-Luc n'a pas été gagné tout de suite
parce que tu succédais quand même à une
émission qui existait pendant 20 ans les
grands du rire donc
c'est 17 ans donc il a fallu peut-être
recréer de nous fidèles et j'imagine que
tu es un peu rajeuné la case également
ça je sais pas honnêtement je connais
pas la structure d'audience de des
grands du rire on sait pas placer
là-dedans c'est juste mis dans ce
sillage là et on a essayé de faire
l'émission qui pourrait rencontrer le
public de France 3 et je crois qu'on
s'assey élargi en plus donc tout ça
c'est des bonnes surprises on a fait ça
plus honnêtement possible alors en fait
voir votre carrière vous êtes vous avez
tout fait sans lui aussi la radio la
télé animateur
regardez on a tout essayé sur France 2
On n'est pas couché sur France de Touche
pas à mon poste évidemment sur France 4
puis sur C8 les pieds dans le patient
Europe 1 engageant passé puis
aujourd'hui culture média et Sophie les
copains sur Europe 1 samedi dernier
évidemment sur France 3 laquelle de
toutes ces expériences vous a le plus
marqué alors celles qui sont en cours on
va les on va les extraire mais laquelle
vous a le plus marqué
c'est pas pour me défausser mais tout
m'a marqué on a tout essayé c'était mes
débuts à la télé j'ai énormément appris
dans la bande à Ruquier On n'est pas
couché aussi ça m'a permis de toucher
autre chose Touche pas à mon poste je
crois que c'est une mission qui marche
pas mal donc c'était une expérience de
malade on est parti sur France 4 et
c'est devenu un phénomène de société
j'ai appris dans tout ça Guess Maye je
pensais pas faire un jeu un jour et je
me suis éclaté comme c'était pas permis
on a retrouvé des petits extraits
évidemment vous imaginez bien Jean-Luc
Lemoine quand vous étiez sur sur C8
quand vous faisiez une 4/3 voilà un
petit extrait pour se souvienne plus
vous appelez qui pour placement
[Applaudissements]
ça a duré deux heures
alors je vais préciser que j'ai deux
personnes qui ont travaillé avec moi sur
les 4/3 il y a une Déborah et il y a eu
aussi desborah qui était la jeune fille
et ma fille est complice pour aller
chercher aussi des offres comme ça on va
commencer ça se passe
les plus sombres de tous les
chroniqueurs mais ce qui était bah oui
c'est vrai parce qu'en fait vous êtes en
régie avec des oreillettes vous avez les
micros de tout le monde et vous notez
tout ce qui est susceptible d'être drôle
et d'être et d'être fait par Jean-Luc et
pour moi c'est l'expérience la plus la
plus intéressante la plus folle que j'ai
fait vous travaillez ensemble donc
Déborah tire
les bons moments les bons moments
Jean-Luc les voyaient tous et puis
ensuite ils construisaient toute la
chronique là dessus et après la pêche
on construisait c'est une rubrique à
l'envers on espérait que la pêche soit
bonne de ce que me ramener Déborah et
puis après je construisais une histoire
la pêche était toujours bonne parce qu'à
un moment franchement on le sait qu'on
va se faire piéger non mais
franchement il mentait pas ils étaient
hyper naturels j'ai jamais eu de moments
où vraiment les mecs se disaient
la seule fois où enfin les seuls fois où
j'ai eu l'impression qu'il forçait un
petit peu le trait on dirait parce que
si ça son défaut d'un seul coup ça
décrédibiliser toute la rubrique donc on
s'est passé pas mal d'extraits et on
oublie les caméras pendant les pubs il
faut vraiment le souligner et il m'est
arrivé d'aller tout voir en disant j'ai
dû dire une connerie pendant la pub
est-ce que tu penses que tu pourrais la
couper et là tu me répondais quelque
chose vraiment brillant j'ai dit écoute
je ne ferai jamais quelque chose qui te
portera des faux voilà j'ai jamais joué
contre l'équipe il y a évidemment des
extraits qu'on a pas pu diffuser avec
Déborah on imagine
alors il y a un autre extrait qu'on a
retrouvé vous avez déclenché un fou rire
quand vous êtes arrivés sur le plateau
avec une perruque
Jean-Luc Lebois un applaudissement pour
lui
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'était pour faire Patrick Sébastien
c'est ça
Patrick Sébastien je porte très mal les
perruques les chapeaux en général et
donc Cyril prenait un malin plaisir à
m'en sur la tête
nous aussi ça nous fait encore
aujourd'hui alors on en est encore une
petite pour la route lors de la millième
de TPMP vous en souvenez ou pas dans la
mienne de TP on a pris que vous avez
passé un casting un peu particulier vous
allez voir il y a Chantal Goya dans
l'affaire
[Musique]
ton regard fait si merveilleux que j'en
ferai pour mes amis mes parents t'ont
aimé
tout de suite
ils ont fait avec ton petit museau
charmant ton costume noir et blanc tu as
fait rire toute la maison pendant son
temps
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
envoyer un message à la semaine dernière
et là c'était une expérience de malade
parce que en fait je savais pas du tout
mais bander les yeux je me suis retrouvé
devant chez Michou et j'ai eu une heure
pour me déguiser en Chine sauf que dans
le public c'était des vrais touristes je
pense qu'ils connaissent c'est
quand même mal fait
non ça faisait la blague en tout cas
j'avais bien fait rire
et Valérie Benaim vous avez fait aussi
un incroyable talent aussi ah oui mais
oui mais là là c'est Cyril qui s'est
fait avoir
vous vous êtes vraiment multicarte
Jean-Luc Le Moine qu'est-ce que vous en
a un extrait c'est génial voilà je vais
te demander Jean-Luc Lemoine
applaudissement
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
12 au carré fois 12 + 1212 - 2 x 12 - 12
par 2 de 1910
2910 je vous jure que c'est la bonne
réponse chez vous vous avez pu vous
répondre
vous êtes beaucoup déguisé
à Cyril il le savait pas et c'est très
difficile de piéger Cyril pendant deux
ans lui a fait croire que j'étais un
génie des maths et il a cru en fait
j'avais
2910 c'est la date de naissance de ma
fille et on faisait que des calculs qui
étaient faux avec la production et
pendant deux ans ça a duré ça a
fonctionné je sais pas si on a des
questions du PAF elle est juste une
petite question quand même de
téléspectateurs elle va s'afficher sur
votre écran c'est Amélie qui vous
demande vous pourrez faire le métier
d'humoriste ou d'animateur
bon vrai métier à la base c'est
humoriste c'est là où j'ai commencé sur
scène donc je suis très attaché à la
scène mais j'adore mon métier
d'animateur vraiment là je suis
complètement épanoui en plus avec samedi
dans rire c'est super on va vous
retrouver en prime ou pas avec sanitaire
d'autres émissions d'humour on travaille
sur des projets on travaille sur des
projets c'est pas encore signé voilà il
y a des choses dans l'air j'ai appris
toi m'avait dit que vous auriez passé
les essais pour tout le monde veut
prendre sa place est-ce que c'est vrai
ou pas